shaving my face like a man no it doesn't
grow back thicker no it doesn't give me
acne i'm a little bit of a skeptic
they never tell you how to not get acne
though because every time i remove hair
from my face any type of way i get acne
but my best friend bree gave me a hat
shave your face like the man and you
won't have acne
let me tell you what i'm talking about
first okay you're going to get a
gillette razor but you're going to turn
it on the back that's what you're going
to use to shape your face then you're
going to use this pinax oil benzoyl
peroxide daily 4
daily control
as your shaving cream and then you'll
follow up with this a little whole
moment
okay
we're gonna shave our face like a man so
we don't get acne let's go don't have a
choice come on come on take my brother's
face
[Music]
cleanser
then you want to pat dry make sure it's
completely dry
i'm just putting it on kind of like a
face mask
very thick layer
make sure you know your baby hair is out
of the way
okay so like i said you're going to get
your gillette razor the yellow one turn
it on its back
and you just start shaving
[Music]
so you can 100
see all that hair
so
it's really just that simple
just go slow and be very careful you can
nick and cut yourself i nicked myself on
my forehead
[Music]
so i wasn't joking be very careful
because you can make yourself
like i did but it's worth it just do it
slower i was doing it on camera so that
made things a little bit difficult but
all right last but not least
with that home loan thing
[Music]
[Music]
let's check my skin outside to see just
how gorgeous it looks
tell me that my skin does not look
gorgeous
it's a great exfoliant gets all the hair
off your skin just be careful shave like
a man and let me know how it goes
[Music]
you